[Music]
[Music]
I don't whoever you are come travel with
me traveling with me you find what never
tires the earth never tires the earth is
rude silent incomprehensible at first
nature is rude and incomprehensible at
first be not discouraged keep on there
are divine things well enveloped I swear
to you there are divine things more
beautiful than words can tell at all we
must not stop here
however sweet these laid up stores
however convenient this dwelling we
cannot remain here however sheltered
this port and however calm these waters
we must not anchor here however welcome
the hospitality that surrounds us we are
permitted to receive it but a little
while I concentrate toward them that are
now I wait on the door slab who has done
his day's work who will soon as to be
through with his supper who wishes to
walk with me will you speak before I am
gone will you prove already too late
the spotted Hawk swoops by and accuses
me he complains of my gab and my
loitering I too am NOT a bit tamed I too
AM untranslatable I sound my barbaric
yawp over the roofs of the world the
last Scud of day holds back for me it
flings my likeness after the rest and
true as any on the shadowed wilds it
coaxes me to the vapor and the dusk
I depart as air I shake my white locks
at the runaway Sun I effuse my flesh in
Eddie's and drifted in lacy Jags I
bequeath myself to the dirt to grow from
the grass I love if you want me again
look for me under your boot soles you
will hardly know who I am or what I mean
but I shall be good health to you
nevertheless and filter and fiber your
blood failing to fetch me at first keep
encouraged missing me one place search
another I stopped somewhere waiting for
you
[Applause]